Apes prject we're going to watch the
kingdom of the Planet of the Apes
trailer today I'm looking forward to
this John good morning how are you good
morning I am I am going to be bananas
for this trailer whoa that's racist
that's racist against Apes n man don't
call them monkeys or chimps or what's
the thing they don't like being called
doesn't matter guys leave a like on that
video that' be very much appreciated
also uh today's video is sponsored by by
better help had a good amount to say
about them I'm in therapy Lord knows we
needed more on them after the
reaction when I
sleep I see strange things oh I love
nature planet Earth
memories not
Memories
wow post aping world looks gorgeous
yeah oh I see
everything falconry of the
Apes that is
not
everything
wowe feels like bad resurrected it
yeah ooo
oh the hot humans
yes staple of every Apes
movie whoa don't tase me
bro now looks like they have a soft spot
for the humans here eight
[Music]
mowgly wow discover the scientific
Technologies the ruins
where's the Statue of Liberty what a
wonderful
[Applause]
day what a glorious
day what a lovely day who it is me and
this franchise is Everlasting I know a
lot of people before this trailer came
out were concerned that with how
fantastic the prior Trilogy was that if
this movie might undo a lot of that
Goodwill of the Revival of the Planet of
the Apes series there's a title right
there Revival of the Planet of the Apes
Oh that's oh that's what you however you
know I got a good amount of thoughts on
this man um because just looking at this
footage and thinking about how far the
Apes have evolved as a civilization
since the events of War for the Planet
of the Apes I'm just thinking it's
really important that these Apes keep
their mental health in check as they go
along and evolve in society you know mhm
it's a really taxing experience and
they're going to need somebody to vent
their problems to help them grow through
the trials and tribulations definitely
New World Order yeah hey John listen I'm
going to just change my clothes really
quick while I talk about better he for
just an obnoxious amount of time and
then we're going to really talk about
this trailer together and I'll stay the
same yeah you stay the same and I'll
change back and do this these clothes
today's episode is sponsored by better
help I know that we often joke around
here quite a bit on the channel but I
wanted to speak a little bit more
sincere during this specific sponsor and
I'll start off by saying this that you
know with any sponsor they usually give
like suggested things to consider uh
when talking about the sponsor and one
of their suggested things was was a
question that they had there that went
along the lines of like have you ever
laid awake with your thoughts racing
wishing for a moment of silence and I
thought to myself well yeah that's my
secret cap like I know that feeling way
too well and it's in those Quiet Moments
where you're battling your own mind
where you are seeking Clarity the most
and you may have heard me talk about
this on the channel before the better
part of a decade now therapy has
undoubtedly been one of my main anchors
before there was ever the real rejects I
was diagnosed with PTSD type 2 bipolar
and ADHD so uh needless to say I needed
some therapy and through its guidance
I've Unearthed deeper layers of myself
cultivated richer relationships and just
have a more profound understanding of my
emotions and one of the best parts about
it is it's giving me a space where it's
free from judgment where I've found my
voice and learn the art of truly
listening not just to others but also to
myself I've talked a little bit about
how this year I've focused a lot more on
my physical health and hit in the gym a
little bit more often and in all
sincerity I do view therapy as like the
a gym for your mental health a place
where you can really nurture your mental
well-being and it is an experience that
has been been quite transformative so
much to the point that you know I would
say at least half of the people that you
see that come here on the channel are in
therapy as a matter of fact I know one
of them their therapist is with better
he I often joke that like I've been in
therapy since it was underground why I
joke like that is because I I see now in
the past few years a lot more people
have been going to therapy which is
fantastic I'd love seeing that so I will
say that if in your heart if you have
been seeking therapy or contemplating
going to therapy I highly encourage you
I urge you to consider Better Health
before I ever saw some ad for better
help I had heard other people who had
been with better help and had really
given strong in-person testimonies to me
their online platform is crafted with
care keeping your comfort in mind
starting it as simple as answering a few
questions and really important to
remember it's a journey and I really
love this because I've had at least like
three therapists in my life so if you
ever feel the need to change your
therapist better help understands and
allows it without any fuss trust me
that's a massive benefit so for a
journey of self-discovery and mental
well-being turn to betterhelp embark on
this heartfelt Joy at betterhelp.com
that's
[Music]
is it exactly the the prequel to The
Original films not a th% but sort of
it's almost like prequel in the sense of
how Daniel Craig's Casino Royale was
like it's a prequel it's an origin story
but it's also a modern day so it's not a
th% it but it could be it's a it's a
contextual prequel more so than a like
100% just linear prequel yeah yeah all
the words that I said in in like 2
minutes John said in 5 seconds it's okay
I wouldn't have known which two words to
pick if you hadn't laid it down I
appreciate that um and here it seems
like that they're going the path of just
kind of
skipping Planet of the Apes the
Charleston hessen version or or they are
um doing no I would say that they are
kind of it seems like they're they're
skipping past like Escape from Planet of
the Apes into the last two original
Planet of the Apes films in that
franchise which is benath Conquest oh
dude you're killing this titles yeah
know I watched the planet of the when I
was a kid and so I I feel like so did I
I just didn't retain the freaking titles
trying to take away the credit from you
here but I I think they are going past
uh War for the credit of the Apes all
right you know what I mean though like
we're focusing here on uh on Cornelius
in a way I mean I feel like this is
Cornelius is it I think so unless they
just swapped out for somebody different
but similar cuz didn't it end with
Caesar's kid yeah having a kid and
Caesar spoil alert dying in the last one
yeah yeah and we have our new ape
Messiah yeah yeah it it seems like we're
kind of what I'm saying is it seems like
they're now in territory where they're
starting to remake the original films
kind of yeah and like this has you know
obviously like the apes are sort of like
reigning Supreme at the moment which in
a different way than some of the later
Apes movies still reminded me of those
where it's like oh now humans are like
second class citizens and they're being
somewhat oppressed by the ape class now
and you know what happens when you know
you you achieve your your Revolution and
you overthrow the status quo and and now
you're in the position of power yeah
well I think they are taking I think now
I I take it back a little bit too that
because you know Planet of the Apes
original one that's when you did see the
the humans were kind of like feral
creatures who were trying to to survive
and it seems like that's what the humans
are like here and our main ape is
probably going to take compassion upon
them while the other apes are thinking
they should be wiped out yeah it seems
like there's a faction between two right
it's like it seems like you would have
people who still remember the struggle
of the previous movie to kind of how can
they it's been so long it seems like
it's a forgotten history right I get
well yeah I I guess it's still
regardless of how close it is I feel
like yeah you would still have camps who
are very much dedicated to the memory of
how and why we got here and the reason
why we can you know never go back to the
old way we need to now basically grip
Supremacy whereas you know yeah
Cornelius might be in the position of
going like hey you know we can only go
so far like I know the humans have done
messed up things to us you know
throughout history however we can't just
become them as part of the impression
that I'm getting is that there's our our
main ape if it is cording Le I'm just
kind of
assuming is looking through uh you know
the ruined civilization kind of like how
you know in the first Planet of the Apes
movie it it seemed like he went to some
other planet yeah where apes were
dominant and humans were just
animalistic right and then you find out
that you're actually in the future and
it seems we're going to be kind of doing
that Journey but of through the
perspective of our main AP protagonist
who is venturing off and then discovers
like the former Human Society what
Humanity used to be yeah you know so
that's why I mean we kind of like remake
different perspective territory where
instead of telling it from a human
perspective you're seeing it from uh the
Apes perspective yeah and I like the
kind of transition visually between
starting off the trailer in such a kind
of planet earthy sort of nature
documentary Vibe where you feel like
you're very removed from any traces of
civilization and then slowly but surely
you start to come into the RO remains of
what was Human Society but now it's all
overgrown and it's become sort of
consumed again by nature yeah yeah I
thought this trailer had a great sense
of wonder uh it it Capt the visuals
looked really strong again you know Andy
Circus brought so much to the role of
Caesar that for the main performers
that's a lot to live up to and I'm
really hoping that they're able to do
that and also you know Matt Reeves
directed Rise of the Planet Apes is
great uh but Matt Reeves is become like
the name for the franchise cuz he did
the the last two films Paul Green Grass
of the a yeah you know he really is
people think that he helmed all three
but he didn't he helmed the last two and
he did a fantastic excellent job and it
seems like aesthetically at
least and there are some shots here that
seem like they're really taking
inspiration from the Matt Reeves Vision
that he had I do want to see what the
distinct voice is to it and it feels a
little bit more uh adventurous like the
Dawn of the Planet Apes and War of the
Planet Apes were very Bleak especially
the last one was so dread heavy and
somber and this feels more
Fantastical yeah I to get the Maze
Runner director makes a lot of sense I
was about to say yeah I I believe it is
that guy and and certainly it does like
that movie at least the first one that I
have seen go check out the reaction it
has uh a bleer approach to the W
setup so like he's good at living in an
environment like this making you feel
like you're roughing it in the elements
and portraying you know the infighting
of you know a struggling you know
Society of one shape or another so like
there are reasons I can I can easily see
why he was chosen and now I'm sort of
waiting to see like okay like by all
accounts it seems like he was able to
sort of elevate some uh certain aspects
of The Maze Runner now can he live up to
you know the shoes left to be filled by
both the Matt re
stretch of the franchise and just the
Legacy it has overall yeah yeah I wonder
if also they want them to kind of do
some revisionist history and sort of
forget about the planet uh the the Human
Society prior like if that's what
they're if that's the journey that we're
watching you know what I mean where
they're going uh like the way how we
have tried to bury things in our history
sure and rewrite and
recontextualize yeah and I and I wonder
if like maybe that's what our villainous
ape is kind of hoping for could be to to
hide it so that way you do get to the
part where you do really marry it to the
original Planet of the Apes where there
was just a select few who knew the truth
yeah this was always their lot in life
they were just always meant to be
peasants serving us these these
structures these are just where the
great apes used to dwell yeah yeah yeah
something like that that would be cool
um anyway guys what do you think about
this trailer are you looking forward to
it are you excited leave your thoughts
down below thank you so much for being
here thank you to better help once again
and uh hey we'll talk with you all very
soon thank you
[Music]
guys